foreign
let me start by showing you a
construction site in my home city of
Oslo
[Applause]
[Music]
did you hear something unusual indeed
the noise the noise you hear was from
the kindergarten nearby not from the
machineries the machines were electric
and so were the trucks that transport
materials to and from the site as head
of a climate agency in Oslo the
clustering a construction site is a
climate measure I'm really excited about
the workers here are opening a stream
that has been confined in pipelines for
more than 120 years
and as climate change in Oslo we are
likely to experience more heavy rain so
we need to improve our storm water
runoff system
an opening creeks and rivers will help
the city to become more resilient and
avoid flooding as well as creating nicer
areas and contributing to biodiversity
in the city
clustering is close to being a Serial
emission construction site run by the
city of Oslo and running theory of
emission size is just one example of the
Oslo climate strategy this is how
downtown of Oslo looked when I moved to
Oslo in 1989. this is the same area
today
oslo's climate measures has given the
city cleaner air less noise
safer and more human-centered streets
some of the measures were controversial
when first introduced but now a majority
of the population thinks even those who
are not that concerned about climate
change think that we are creating a
better City
for too long discussions about climate
change has been about sacrifice I am
here to tell you that climate Solutions
actually make better City and a better
quality of life for everyone
this is only the first of five lesson we
have learned on our journey to become an
emission-free City
and I think this lesson can be implied
almost anywhere
so I like to share them so lesson number
one
confronting climate change is about
creating better cities and better
quality of life for everyone
including those kids in the kindergarten
that don't have to share the days with
noisy escalators
the second lesson is about being
ambitious
in 2015 the city council set a target of
reducing greenhouse gas emission by 95
by 2030 without purchasing any carbon
offsets so aiming for real reductions
commitment to this goal change of a
mindset
if we were going to reach its Target
every Department had to get active
figure measures and finding out how to
implement them so second lesson be
ambitious a Target measured in years not
decades
provides no excuse for inaction
in my experience the key challenges of
achieving climate targets is that the
vision of responsibility we see on
global national and local level
in the city the same is true there are
differences inside the administration
between departments and between agency
which each have their own targets and
own responsibility unrelated to climate
just and their own budget to stick to
this makes it very difficult to
coordinate climate measures which often
cross sexual boundaries our solution
to this fragmentation
was this document
the Oslo climate budget
which we put forward for the first time
in 2016. the first climate budget as far
as we know a climate budget is a
governance tool it structures and
organize how we can get from climate
Target policies onwards to action and
results
it's also make all part of the
administration in Oslo a stakeholder to
The Climate goals our climate budget
which is measured in tons of CO2
emission is fully integrated in the
municipal budget
and like the financial budget the
climate budget is the responsibility of
the deputy mayor of Finance
it presents the expected emission
reduction from the adopted climate
measures and it clearly states what has
to be done by whom when Amber relevant
at what necessary budgetary cost
let me give you one example in 2022 the
city council decided to invest in a
carbon capture and storage facility at
the largest waste incineration plant in
Oslo this is the single biggest emission
Source in Oslo coating for 17 of the
total
this is a measure that has been planned
in the climate budget since 2017 and it
will be the Department of Business
Development and public ownership with
its specific skills that will have the
responsibility for implementing it and
the carbon will be captured from 2026
and onwards
that's the third lesson learned a
comprehensive government system is key
to distribute responsibility and to keep
the responsible Unity accountable
an important point is that every agency
will have to report on the status of
their climate work
as a part of the ordinary budget process
three times a year
so let me go back to Construction
three years ago we broke ground on the
piloting of the first world first zero
emission construction site the agency of
urban environment was
transforming a busy street into a
pedestrian Zone in this city center of
Oslo
they were using powerful machineries to
lift and break slabs of assault even
though the Machinery was so quiet that
the next work Affairs and restaurant
kept their front doors open
today we have more than 30 such sites
even though electric construction
Machinery barely existed prior to this
project
this change be made through procurement
in 2017 the city decided to use
procurement to drive markets for
developing Technologies we needed to
reach the climate goals like in every
city
construction is a big emission source
and in Oslo the municipality account for
approximately 20 percent that everything
that is being built of a procurement
framework Awards companies who can
provide zero emission services in since
2019
all projects by the municipality has
used this as a core tender Criterium
this is important for contractors
because it creates a predictable demand
for zero emission Solutions
other city in Norway has started using
the same kind of criteria and the result
is that the availability of zero
emissions machines are increasing every
year in Norway
so fourth lesson never ever
underestimate how much you can change by
being a demanding customer
when
key strength of markets is their
adaptability and when you play to that
strength it is surprisingly how much you
can change in a short time we plan to
gradually introduce requirements with
zero emission in all construction sites
in the city of Oslo both private and
public by 2030.
the last years the city's quality of air
has improved significantly two years a
columnist wrote that the city smells so
nice now in the summer the reason are
reduced traffic and the dramatic rise in
proportion of electric cars and buses
sometime technology development exceed
our expectations ten years ago few would
have forecast the numbers we see today
82 percent of all New Path centers
course and 36 percent of new Vans have
so far in 2022 been zero emission and I
think even better 30 of new heavy
vehicles have so far in biogas or
Atlantic
this is very good news because Mobility
is the biggest emission Source in the
city accounting for approximately 50
percent of our total emissions
transition to Electric Mobility has been
supported by a wide range of policies
these include tax national tax exemption
a local investment in an effective
network of charging points but
procurement has played an important role
here too
everything the municipality buy should
be delivered by zero emission transport
this has been and still is a gradual
process but if three providers can offer
it zero a mission become the minimum
criteria in the procurement
everyone probably know that Norway is an
oil and gas Rich nation and many might
think that this is the reason why we can
invest in climate Solutions in Oslo
while the reality is that infrastructure
for public transport walking and biking
are financed by a system of toll roads
we have a toll ring in Oslo and to go
into that zone a non-electrical vehicle
have to pay a high price
and that price will increase with 40
percent the first of January 2024.
this has not been easy no negotiations
and taxes are always controversial but
this is important incentives to
transition away from fossil fuels
sometimes technology development
changed markets very rapidly our climate
budget had a goal of reaching zero
emission public transport by 2028 thanks
to decreased costs and advanced
technology we are now heading for
reaching that goal five years away
the city's Trump and meters are already
electric and nearly all the ferries are
electric and by the end of 2023 every
buses in Oslo will be electric as well
bus drivers love this development
because an electric bus is more pleasant
to drive
and it create no noise nor gausses so
fifth lesson learned don't underestimate
how technology changed markets and how
fast these changes can happen and how we
can incentivize them by using the right
kind of policies
well
we still have a way to go our latest
climate budget analysis shows that we
are up for reaching a reduction with the
adaptable measures by 62 percent by
2030. so we are doing well but we have
to do more and we need to develop assist
for instance we need to develop a system
for integrating indirect emissions
emissions produce old style Oslo that is
related to the activities and life in
the city but we are working on it
let me finish by telling you how I move
around in the city I walk
I haven't mentioned two core aspects of
urban Mobility yet walking and biking
the city began to years ago to develop
two as a city for Walkers and bikers and
that's one of the things that I really
love about the city thinking of a city
this way is about thinking how you
organize your everyday life how where
you can buy your groceries or whether
you can go to work whether your kids can
use their bicycle to dispose activities
this is about streets it's about
locations it is about safe cycling paths
and shortcuts for walking and connecting
it all to the rest of the city we are a
clean public transport
the latest Norwegian National survey
showed that 37
of all daily tips in Oslo is done by
walking
so despite our very long and cold winter
we have become a city of workers
and increasingly if you walk past the
construction site in Oslo you will hear
no noise of course unless there is a
kindergarten next by thank you
[Applause]